I could do a whole hour on Hillary
Clinton yeah she's a very broken person
um and Donald Trump largely broke her
her whole life was about becoming
president her whole life from when she
went to Maine East High School in
Chicago when she went to Wellesley her
whole life was in preparation her
marriage to Bill Clinton what a con that
was right from her running the bimbo
squad for bill which was literally the
same thing that they're indicting Donald
Trump for Bill Clinton had a whole
operation a whole team you could look it
up bimbo Squad where they were just went
and they went to women that Donald Trump
um had not Donald Trump that Bill
Clinton had sex with and then they would
just do NDA after NDA after NDA
um and it was well known in the 90s and
people forget about it yep see Giuliani
says Clinton's in uh employed a bimbo
Squad you go downpolitico.com 2016. yes
Hillary was an enabler right she was the
Chief Architect she was the Michael
Cohen of Bill Clinton's NDA operation in
the 90s and look I'll be very honest I
don't love the argument well Democrats
do those crime times and why should
Republicans be applied because I just
think it's overdone in this case it's
actually a good argument which is that
Bill Clinton mastered the private payoff
NDA like he was he was the best at it he
would go sleep with a woman she would go
threaten to go to the news and then he
would throw the bimbo Squad and settle
for a hundred thousand dollars right
they never indicted him and by the way
while we're talking about people's you
know sexual behaviors can we have maybe
a grand jury and paneled for Bill
Clinton getting on Jeffrey Epstein's
plane and going down because I guess
former presidents are now you know
completely
fair game
it's also one side of the aisle right
this is the it was both sides on the
well no no Trump never went to the
island that is not true Trump and
Epstein hated each other there's a lot
of misinformation that Netflix did a lot
of damage here Trump kicked Epstein out
of the club he never went to the island
there's no evidence he ever engaged in
the Epstein's nonsense in fact he kicked
Epstein out because he was preying on
young women Bill Clinton did go to the
island dershowitz went to the island and
maybe some other people that's what we
know of but Trump never went to the
island
it's so funny that this this whole thing
takes place and nobody is willing to
open it up and go deeper to see what
really happened there you know what was
uh who do we have on a couple months ago
who talked about the Epstein Island Rob
who was who who do we have on what was
her name she was Whitney which by the
way she did a phenomenal job and she
can't even live in the states yeah they
loved what she had to say what what's
the likelihood that we'll ever in our
lifetime learn about what happened on
Epstein Island and you know any of the
guys that will be held accountable for
it what's the number below zero hmm
you really think it's not going to
happen at all oh yeah I mean so my my
hypothesis on Epstein he was an
intelligence asset either for the
American government or for the Israelis
he had a potemkin village of an
investment facade anyone that met him
there's a very powerful YouTube video
Eric Weinstein talks about this in
detail so this is not my theory he talks
about it he says when I sat down with
Jeffrey Epstein it makes sense because
he had the most expensive real estate
and he wasn't that sophisticated in how
he talked about Investments and there
were not a lot of recorded trades on the
addresses he disclosed for his financial
activity and he only had one investor
and it's all very strange right but it
makes sense that if you were trying to
run an intelligence operation either but
for the Saudis or for the Israelis or
for the American government that you
would try to get the most powerful
people in compromising situations with
underage girls capture it on film and
then be able to use it and blackmail for
blackmail so
I don't know all the details but you're
dealing with something that's deeper
than just kind of a high society pimp
that's essentially what Whitney Webb did
point out it was it wasn't even
necessarily Epstein it was his uh
right-hand woman yeah that her father
was undoubtedly some sort of assets and
he owned newspapers and he was a
Powerhouse Rupert Murdoch and him went
at it yeah that's exactly his name
Robert Maxwell yes so you're saying less
than zero percent right the fact that we
find out what actually happened on the
island it's not it's not going to happen
who would lead that charge though you
know you see a January 6 committee or
911 committee but I mean that that the
only advocating for that only one person
could Trump no no no no it's it's it's
like yeah yeah oh uh uh what do you call
these uh um
Wikileaks guy uh Julian Assange
it's got to be somebody like that and
you got to be living in a different
place to pull it off and hack into it
and gather the community because they
have communicated so there's some way
somebody can't get to the island too
that's right Bill Gates went to the
island I'm sorry I forgot but Bill Gates
went to fix the Microsoft Outlook email
for Epstein because he was having
problems it wasn't just the island it
was this massive ranch in New Mexico too
right huge Ranch that underage girls
were trafficked to and remember this
wasn't just American government
officials
Prince Harry right is that it no not
Harry not Prince William Edward Prince
Edward Randy Andy yeah prince Andrew
Andrea call him again
no no Harry is yeah he's a whole
different from Santa Barbara yeah prince
Andrew
was also uh part of Epstein's orbit so
did you see uh uh just to bring up Harry
if you want to recognize them they're
non-profit they have to prove how many
hours a week they contribute a total
nonprofit you know how many hours they
have to prove did you see it one hour a
week
nice that's hard work 11 million dollars
I believe they've raised what's 30
million dollars they've raised they've
given three million three million
dollars and they contribute an hour a
week to their charity that's some
hard-working people right there one
final thing on the Epstein thing I don't
mean to belabor the point but when I
first started to go to Palm Beach and I
visited Palm Beach 10 years ago I
started to hear kind of one-off comments
about oh yeah that house right there uh
that's Jeffrey Epstein and he's uh
trafficking young girls people knew in
the area and then you're 19 at the time
I was 19 20 years old yeah they were
just casually point this out no it was a
matter of fact because remember Epstein
was indicted like 15 years prior for
similar activity so it was kind of out
there right yeah uh I think it was a
cost to actually that was the U.S
attorney general ended up being one of
Trump's cabinet officials that was the
U.S attorney I could be wrong about that
but there was some connective tissue
there and anyway no one really took it
seriously and then I remember it was
either Rogan or somebody in 14 or 15
before all this started to talk about
Epstein's Island and you were smeared as
a conspiracy theory
as a cons if you would have said in 15
in public decent society that there was
a
targeted campaign with former presidents
and the world's richest man who Bill
Gates was at the time to go to a remote
island in the Caribbean to go be able to
have sex sexual relationships with
underage girls you would have been
laughed out of the room now we know
that's a fact why do I say that be
careful what you call a conspiracy
theory it's a thought-terminating cliche
that actually might lead you to
something true so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]